what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Michael Dunn Werth
is the co-founder of wire a company
focused on connecting crypto companies
to the fiat world we had a great
conversation in this episode about rugby
why'd nerds go to Silicon Valley how to
build compelling products and how wire
is building the essential infrastructure
for Fiat on and off ramps I really
enjoyed this one so I hope you do as
well
all right guys bang bang I've got a
Michael here he came all the way to New
York City on a day where it's about 18
degrees outside so thanks for for coming
to do this yeah no worries still
defrosting but thanks for having me I
appreciate it and as you can hear his
voice he is not used to the cold so
we're gonna get through this but let's
uh let's start with uh with time in
Australia right so born in born and
raised there
yep Sydney Australia got it what's that
like fantastic beaches naught minus 8
degrees Celsius it's yet beautiful
people are chilled very easygoing sunny
happy yeah yeah and growing up you play
sports like what was kind of the life
experience in Australia as you grew up
yeah yeah I mean rugby and cricket
basically it's all about it I sucked it
both and I played both I was in the F's
for rugby I went to like a full-on rugby
nursery so to speak like that would
produce it was renowned for rugby and
stuff like that but I had no
contribution to that at all so what is a
rugby nursery oh it's like a breeding
ground for like talk to your talent
basically oh really yeah a prep school
yeah exactly it's like a it's a school
is you know all Catholic boys school
basically and you would go there you get
shown like how to play rugby really well
I mean it's not a rugby school but
they're renowned for producing fantastic
rugby players so got it and growing up
so rugby and cricket both are not very
big in the United States obviously we
have you know baseball and football and
things like that yeah
he's like every kid's dream too
be a professional rugby player yeah
exactly so I mean most of the time you
grow up sort of like oh I want to you
know I think it's changed a little bit
now because rugby's sort of got a bit
stagnant in like yeah it's a boring game
compared to other games but most people
grow up wanting to be a wallaby like
that's the you know the Australian
Wallabies is like the term for national
rugby team Oh
got it yeah it's like that is the team
if you can get on the national
Australian rugby team you are like a god
and Australia basically yeah
yeah and fun fact actually the five
eight which is a position like let's say
quarterback the five eight for the u.s.
in the World Cup is Australian really
yeah
oh he was actually like you know two
World Cups ago one more category yeah
got it
my Curtis and I guess what's interesting
about this is things like rugby cricket
etc it takes a lot of time right is is
what I understand in terms of it's not
just like hey t of the skills but like
the physicality specifically at rugby is
very similar to American football that
where you yeah where you've got to work
out a lot and its speed its powers all
this stuff and I played American
football you know all the way through
college I don't understand how these
dudes are playing without pads on it's
nuts okay so like this is the thing and
I feel like a lot of people have
analyzed this a bunch but when you're
playing with pads I feel like that could
actually be more just I'm just gonna
throw everything at this person right
because they okay pads on so you're
going to be more confident to you know
there's gonna be less repercussions but
if I know them I'm gonna break my
collarbone like driving it into you you
know your hip then I'm going to be more
strategic in how I'm gonna tackle you or
something like that
oh so you're making the argument that
because there's no pads actually might
be safer I would actually say so yeah
Wow huh I never thought of it that way
neither and I until I watched someone
that was like smart and like talking
about stuff it is like actually we did
the research and it's like I mean but
like NFL is nolle like people are you
know six eight they run a hundred meter
dash and you 11 flat or something it is
mental i I just imagine somebody like a
Sean Taylor
who you probably that is but he's uh he
was basically he played safety so on
defense an American football
he's the farthest guy back yeowch means
that anything could happen in front of
them basically he can run forward and
just level them right and so he was
notorious for pretty much using almost
no technical form in Tekamah Kazi he
just would we scold torpedo move right
basically some guys running across the
middle I'm gonna launch myself as hard
as I can into this person and hope that
I dislodge the human from the ball he
was really good at it I don't know if it
was Jared
so Jarryd Hayne for he was hane playing
or hane train or whatever he was an
Australian you know NF NRL player and I
was like rugby is a different code of
rugby says rugby league rugby union he
came over to play with the 49ers
actually oh that was like four years ago
I think maybe five and he was boiling
hot like buzz everywhere everyone's like
oh my god this dude he's gonna tear it
up he crushed it in like I think like
qualifying or preliminary like the
preseason stuff yeah and I don't
actually know what happened in the I
think it was a rugby player who came to
play American football yes that's right
and he toured up in the preseason stuff
and then I think you know come like the
actual season he just couldn't couldn't
hold up basically yeah yeah it's
physical man you guys are crazy
yeah alright so how do you go from rugby
nursery - yeah - you came to San
Francisco with 2013 yeah what was the
the impetus for uh for crossing over
that massive ocean that's who come to
the tech capital of the world
okay so the easiest like the too long
didn't raid is actors go to Hollywood
nerds go to San Francisco that's kind of
the s probably fair yeah so you know you
like you you pack up your bags at one
way trip and all that kind of stuff yeah
I just wanted like I was like well I'm
young enough I'm you know the narrative
hasn't kicked in yet
and by narrative I mean you know you get
the house the family car mortgage blah
blah blah and then wife's
but sort of the opportunity to take
chances is you know dwindling
exponentially from there so I was
working in finance and I did a start-up
in in Australia on the side so it's sort
of like you working you know finance and
that was like 7:00 a.m. till 7:00 p.m.
and then you know you'd hustle after
that after hours or you do like business
development in your lunch break and
stuff and ended up selling that to not
like exiting like a bazillion dollars
but we made money on it and that was
like a oh [ __ ] that's awesome I'm sorry
for swearing Billy you're absolutely I
swear
just get it out the [ __ ] few but you
know like once I did I was like oh my
god that's awesome but the problem is
like Australia is small in California by
population so like if you really got an
itch to scratch like I want to build
something and make people's lives better
like you may as well start with your you
know best foot forward so you got to
roll the dice and you go to the place
that has the highest probability of
success and that's you know at the time
San Francisco I feel like that will
change a lot with distributed teams and
you know things like that but yeah for
me that was a no-brainer got it and into
when you get to San Francisco you have
like a plan or was it just let me get
there and I'll figure it out once I get
there so I did go with the plan and it
was like I had sort of a next idea that
I was working on and had like you know
friends that were supporting me with
this idea and so like you know that was
sort of like hey I'll back you into the
next idea but I got I got there and I
realized like after grinding for like
the first sort of three or four weeks
like I was like the idea is to get rid
of the idea and like I'm limiting myself
by coming here with pre like I don't
know what I'm in for so I better just
wipe the slate clean forget about what I
thought I knew and start fresh and the
first person I met or one of the first
first people was the person on the bunk
bed above me so bunk beds it was like 20
people this place was like it was an
orphanage with Wi-Fi the term I would
give it basically like literally there
was like 25 people in one just hallway
it was like a hostel
uh I wish or that'd be a friendly term
it was a 26 years like some 26 year old
there's paying the $3,000 a month rent
and he's subletting it out to yet 20
people and making 20 grand a month
literally those numbers and yeah and you
get there and what's the first place
okay so I'll tell you about so like I'm
they coming over like are cool Silicon
Valley like it's where everything
happens get that first person I try to
open the door to the place that I was
staying at and the first person like ran
out the door
bumped I knocked my bag over and he's
like oh I'm sorry I'm running to this
meeting with andreessen horowitz and I
was like whoa cool like I'm here like
the only thing I read about is like
hacking news and all this sort of stuff
and like I was like wow I really am in
the circle-jerk now this is awesome
yeah yeah yeah you get there's 20 people
on laptops or building [ __ ] and you're
like holy [ __ ] alright this is cool yeah
like the show Silicon Valley like they
could not have done a better job in
depicting it yeah first person I met on
the you moved on the top bunk bed above
me was he's still my co-founder today so
really yeah yeah that's amazing and and
so as as you're kind of getting settled
in and you're realizing hey this culture
is pretty real and people here just want
to build etc yeah what will you do it
were you can't looking for an idea or
kind of what were you doing yeah it's a
good question I came over with like
retail like I said I came over pretense
that I was working on that and it was
sort of just eating away that that was
not the right way to to do this journey
like you know to follow up like to
execute on what I'd wanted to do which
is try and build something cool I felt
like I was doing myself a disservice so
what was I doing I suppose just working
away at it but more just soaking it in
and I remember being so like really
lonely because it was like you know
you've one-way ticketed yourself and
like entrepreneur grinding is really
[ __ ] hard anyway and it's it's hard
if you don't have people around you that
are supporting you or invested mentally
in what you're doing day to day and and
I remember like you know calling people
calling my friends now like I was like
you know I feel like maybe the wrong
business
stuff like that and they were just like
no just like soak it up and you know
worst-case scenario three months goes by
you have a bunch of fun you meet a bunch
of new people and you've got an
experience under your belt best case
scenario you come back in ten years with
a really cool story and yeah I feel like
it was it was a really hard time at the
time yeah yeah
and part of this I guess is it feels
like a lot of people go to Silicon
Valley and they have a preconceived
notion of what they want to do right
like yes I'm gonna do X and I think one
of the things I took away when I first
got there and I think a lot of people do
is a lot of what makes Silicon Valley so
powerful and beautiful is that the
people who get it are the people who
realize no I'm gonna run a bunch of
experiments and I'm gonna let the
results tell me where to go right and
that's a very nuanced but important
difference where this belief that like
I'm gonna implement my will on the world
is probably not actually nearly as
accurate as hey I think the world's
heading in this direction let me go run
a bunch of tests and I'll take that
feedback and then I'll kind of evaluate
again you know write a bunch of tests
reiterate it yeah and in that kind of
iterative experimenting type approach
get you much closer to the truth they'll
get you much closer to you know the ever
elusive product market fit then yeah let
me go implement my will on the world and
like I'm right they're wrong that what
idiots know I failed because everyone
else is stupid they didn't understand
that I think the key thing with that is
generally speaking like to be wrong at
[ __ ] or to be wrong in general which is
what you're sort of saying is someone
was saying they're right and everyone
else is wrong right
the reality is timing and being right is
one of the same like that is the the
chemistry for execution right and a lot
of that comes down to humility how good
you are being wrong how fast are you
being wrong basically because you want
to be like especially in like obviously
digital currencies in Bitcoin you want
to be wrong really really [ __ ]
quickly yeah it is so fast it is
it's an entire kind of community of
people who understand that that testing
and iteration is really important and
part of what I think has um has really
been seared into my brain from from
living there and working there excetera
was this idea of we've got to be really
good at designing the tests so
understanding what are we testing why
are we testing it and how are we gonna
test it you know and then executing
perfectly like one of the best pieces of
kind of or the one of the best things I
took away from my time at Facebook was
this idea of in order to run successful
test you need to do two things you need
to measure and you need to execute
perfectly right and execute perfectly
usually gets left out but what ends up
happening is if I run a test and I don't
execute it perfectly and when I get the
results if it doesn't work I'm left
wondering did this not work because it
actually is an invalid test like we
should move on it's a bad idea or did it
not work because we didn't execute it
perfectly and therefore now we're left
and we gotta go run the test again of
course and like this is one of the
things so you know if like I suppose
like just in in the premise of me moving
to San Francisco right and that is me
saying I want to run the test for can I
do something really really cool and
build something that adds value you're
millions of people like I don't know I'm
still on the journey but like we're
figuring it out as we go right but that
is me saying I don't want to leave any
stone unturned so that if I'm 50 or
whatever and the story goes by and I'm
like I could have done that [ __ ] you
could have you didn't do it but now
there's no excuse so if I don't do it
there was no no excuse other than I
couldn't get it done but I tried and I
know I absolutely tried with every
single ounce of energy and opportunity
that I could basic yeah for sure yeah I
guess it's like multivariant testing
multivariate testing is just numbskull
stuff you can never know what the
contributing factor was if you've got
thirty different things that you change
for sure and so as you're kind of going
through this evolution and kind of
soaking in Silicon Valley for all its uh
at the time it's just dirt
thirteen probably of its glory yeah um
well where do you eventually intersect
with Bitcoin blockchain crypto like
what's the first time you you hear about
it and kinda what was your reaction so I
was already into it before I came over
not not into it I was nowhere near into
it I thought it was cool you know
friends of mine were like going in and
bought some bought some together and I
just like trucked in money at the time
and yeah I think it was yeah that was
2012 or 2013 or something yeah and some
more aware of it then I was like I was
like cool yes wait there's this thing I
had no idea what it would do
why it's good or anything like that I
just had sort of like Yolo kind of thing
but yeah I've try to think that uh yeah
basically after that I was like okay
cool when we came over here we were just
sort of like when I came over here I was
sort of just intrigued by it because
obviously it was going on a massive bull
run right this is 2013
we just had Silk Road got closed I think
it was in 2013 and that caused a bit of
a you know kerfuffle and then they had I
think you guys call it the c-span or
whatever the live YouTube stream where
they're like yes coinbase is an MSB but
they can still operate never I was like
ah bull run basically and then China
goes mental and next thing you know it's
a $1,200 Bitcoin but getting into it it
was actually from like an actual product
my co-founder and I we're trying to
build a one-click checkout on the
Internet so you go shop on thirty
websites you checkout enter your payment
details once and we were like oh [ __ ]
why don't we have Bitcoin like bitcoins
kind of cool it's novel and like it
could you know get some attention that
might help drive awareness we did it and
then overnight it was just like the top
of Bitcoin subreddit and they just did
not stop supporting us really and we
literally like three days they were like
oh [ __ ] like close the doors this is a
Bitcoin like that's all we give a [ __ ]
about now
yeah and literally that was the start of
it and and so it goes back to this idea
though of like you were building a bunch
of different things and all of a sudden
the data was overwhelming
hey there's something here and you guys
saying let's go focus there and kind of
don't worry about anything else let's go
where people are pulling us into you got
to be diner driven like yeah it's it's
literally I don't know why you would
never ever want to quantify your
decisions if you have the opportunity to
all you're gonna do is you're looking
for an excuse honest when the excuse not
to have an excuse is being shoved right
in front of your face it's data data
data like listen to it it will it's
there to help you yeah now it makes
sense
and so once you guys start focusing on
Bitcoin and kind of this one check or
one click payment you know how do you
get from that
whoa Bitcoin is real we should focus on
it to wire today
what's that journey look like so very
iterative basically so like the vision
was always you know I we've always been
the vision ears we don't have a vision
and that's like a very fair statement to
make because at the time it manages
expectations so when you hire people if
you hire really talented people when you
say we're gonna be the leading Bitcoin
checkout company and then we added you
know let's say we added five different
altcoins
that's not gonna sit well with someone
that's got a league a lot of conviction
who's a very talented developer that
wants to work on Bitcoin being you know
as big as it can be and so you lose
talent and talent retention becomes
tricky when you have a vision so we've
always said the space is too early to
have a vision so we're just iterated so
start it at the checkout and then we
thought well the next iteration if
you're a checkout like a browser
extension right very similar to what
lolly is lolis really popular if we go
the next iteration would be will brands
we were saying we would have enough data
to see who is shopping where we could go
to Amazon or gotas are or go to Newegg
me like integrate it natively it's worth
it here's the dollar value that it's
gonna return to you guys if not the
promotional value and so the next
iteration was native merchants checkout
so like a bit pay competitor and then as
you build that you start realizing that
spending only happens when people have
made 500x ROI in like twelve months so
you're like all right cool what's next
a less seasonal version of it is wallets
so people are still gonna buy but in
that market like 2014-2015 wallets
weren't a sustainable business yet
because the you know the ocean wasn't
big enough now it is big like it's huge
you've got bear market bull market if
you are a brokerage service you're
worried about the competitive market
saturation more than you're worried
about oh no its crypto winter no-one's
coming outside to buy Bitcoin all of
them and so as you iterate on that yeah
I don't know that makes sense by the way
no it does and so I guess really as
you're thinking through where do we go
you'd guess had done a lot of stuff
right so one of my favorite stories is
this idea of the superhero laundry
service explain what you guys did there
and I think that'll help illustrate you
know your guys openness to just trying a
bunch of different things seeing what
stays yeah yeah that's a good point so
we did basically we had writer's block I
supposed to see equivalent like what you
saw judge banging head against the wall
can't can't get past the next milestone
so we stopped you know my co-founder and
I and we said what's the most non this
thing we can do right now like the
complete opposite of what we're doing
and what we did was basically started a
laundry hero like a superhero laundry
delivery service so you basically put in
an order you say when you want us to
pick it up we pick it up 5:00 a.m. in
the morning drop it off that night and
you pick the super hit the super hero
right so like Superman Batman Superman
Batman and spider-man I think it was and
so our buddy this is so funny our buddy
was like oh I shook on Batman and it
we're like okay sweet
everyone wants Batman why the [ __ ] would
I want to get up at 4:30 in the morning
to dress as Batman you know one week
later he's like getting real tired of
his [ __ ] guys and he's sitting there
putting his Batman outfit on but but
yeah we did that and that was awesome
because it was completely different got
a lot of traction because when you show
up with Batman at 7 a.m. and a you know
a five-year-old answers the door ready
to go to kindergarten that five-year-old
is now your shill basically your
internal referral loop amongst mum and
dad to go you know why didn't Batman
come and pick it up again
yeah it was lots of fun that's awesome
and really it sounds like you guys tried
it hey it's got a little bit of traction
but might not be the most scalable thing
in the world to send people in costumes
running around San Francisco picking up
laundry yeah we made we made a decision
sort of like it would it would either go
the direction of like oh is this gonna
become like lyft or uber where you open
it up and you see different
neighborhoods where it's like heroes and
villains and you see little like hero
and villain icons sort of like which one
do you want to pick up your laundry kind
of thing but that would be sort of
giving it a nudge and I felt like
there's better things in the world to do
than another laundry delivery service
which is you know catering to us lazy
fortunate people that are being you know
focused on convenience and not adding
value for sure and so as you were
building wire right and understanding
that Bitcoin itself I think a lot of the
kind of testing and the open-mindedness
to try new things
it seems like you guys have found a very
specific niche in helping people go from
fiat currency to crypto and all of the
technical rails and kind of
infrastructures needed but also on the
licensing front maybe describe what you
guys are doing today and then we can go
through kind of the work that's gone
into to get to this point yeah yeah so
basically you know Fiat - crypto you
know when you put your card down you
make a payment you get Bitcoin you
wallet that's really hard to do and
there's a reason why it's such a pain in
the ass for everyone to go buy crypto
like you know you go sign up a coin base
or anywhere most of the time you're
gonna go blood sample stroke of your
hair you star psy and shirt off your
back selfie everything that is all
because they need to do that because of
the risk and compliance association with
doing it and so as everyone's going
through this ourselves included we
realized to build our company we had to
actually get all these same licenses and
MSB and all this all this knowledge
that's just like a you know it's a big
vacuum of resources time energy and
capital and so when we did it we were
like oh I mean [ __ ] everyone's gonna do
this no chance yep we should product
Isis this is our journey so you know
some people grow up and is like oh I
lived in a country we couldn't send
money internationally so I moved and
started Western Union and that's their
pain point they sold in Bravo and that's
fantastic I was very fortunate I didn't
have that pain point the pain point I
had was I was trying to build a FinTech
company and I was just getting
slaughtered at every angle trying to get
it done not trying to sides go like
trying to play ball but it's like you
gotta have a lot of money to play ball
and so as we did it we you know over the
years we did our and we're like [ __ ]
we've got to just give this to people so
that the whole industry can move fast
enough because the window of opportunity
we have for like digital currencies to
be as impactful as they can be is finite
the big donate the small to cricket the
slow and that's way to say that again
the big don't eat the small the quick
eat the slow that's that's a really good
say I never heard that before the big
don't eat the small the quick quick slow
that's right that's one of the things
like trying well I feel like I'd be to
beating a dead horse Bay in the drum but
we always say that it worked like I mean
not at work because it's not that it
never feels like work but you know like
in the office it's like I mean a
mentality we were very sort of like if
you ask people that work there I feel
like they'd say that that's exactly one
of them so there's a there's an
Instagram account that you just made me
think of it's called nature is metal so
I found what's your favor like do you
see the shocked crocodile one I've seen
a lot of them nature is metal like that
is the best description of it yeah all
right so just so people understand
there's an Instagram account it's at
nature is metal and what it basically
does is it takes photos or videos from
just hardcore wildlife so you can get on
there next thing you know you see a lion
eating an alligator or you see a snake
that has the two feet of a rabbit you
know right before it swallows
I mean just it's really gruesome and
it's really it's raw like it's like you
know it's not national like that's the
real National Geographic this is hunt or
be hunted this is the food chain this is
how you know the world works kind of
thing so it is it's the type of account
that you follow when you want a daily or
multi multiple times a day reminder of
there's this saying I see people post
all over Instagram that's uh
this life is a hundred percent on you no
one's coming to save you right yeah
that's actually what nature is and in
your heart that I like about this
account is yeah they've got the the
crazy I saw a video there the other day
where basically a lion was running and
or a leopard or something right and it
caught like an antelope yeah and it's
just you know again the the quick eat
the slow and all this kind of scene yeah
yeah but the the ones that get me are
the ones that are really gruesome where
you see the you know the Panther after
its eaten the prey and it's savage blood
everywhere yep and you look at it you're
just like that is the animalistic nature
right it just it needed to eat had to
like and so what did it do it killed to
eat exactly that's what it has to do to
survive end of story
it's not emotional in anything like that
it is fight or flight yeah that's yeah
and so to me you know there's a little
bit of sidetrack but it's one of those
accounts that it's a mentality thing
it's really interesting to to see so
everyone go check out at nature is metal
I should get whoever runs that account
to come on oh yeah interesting yeah but
but I do think the quote that they said
there's like everything's on you so well
there's some different variations of a
basically this life is 100% your
responsibility well no one's coming to
save you true it's so true like and you
know it's funny like I remember you
before like when I was young I had to
write out a thousand lines which is yeah
you do some of you [ __ ] up in school and
you got to do it and I remember mm dude
oh man yes tough question like hey write
50 and go take a day
zurk break yeah right they caught wind
of those your 10 pens attached to each
other so they pushed it up from a
hundred to a thousand but it said
whatever it is to be is up to me and now
ever it is to be is up to me and it's
yeah this is not a dress rehearsal this
is is it yeah and like it lump it hate
it love it whatever it is you just got
to manage your own expectations and
realize that's the case you're gonna
[ __ ] up you're gonna drop the ball like
like I wouldn't say we but I definitely
know myself and as a company like we're
really good at being really [ __ ] at
stuff and that's a fantastic attribute
especially in a fast-moving industry the
faster you can be like oh man I look
like [ __ ] in the mirror today or not
that's how we're judging the company but
you know they say a friend tells you you
look good your best friend tells you you
look like [ __ ] yeah if you look like
[ __ ]
and I feel like we're very good as a
team and as individuals on the team
because everyone is so bright and this
industry is full of really brilliant
people but if you're not humble enough
to iterate on your own opinions you want
to be discovering you don't want to be
right you want to get the right answer
what you don't know what do you do when
you identify that you're bad at
something usually take too long to make
the decision to cut the arm off or
whatever it is you know obviously you
want to make that decision as fast as
possible but yeah you you just sort of
you make a change you identify though
but do you bring in somebody who's good
at it do you try to get better at it we
do well I mean first you have to
identify it right you can't fix anything
until you identify that it is a problem
and I think identifying a problem as a
team it's not about oh just doing
someone a favor to say okay well will
cater to your opinion it's like no no
guys we've all got to see this is this a
problem can we move forward successfully
in the long term short term man maybe
you know don't do don't fix something
because I'm asking let's understand why
it is a problem because then you know
you're infinitely going to grow in
alignment if that's the case but if
you're doing me if
it's not gonna be a long-term successful
opportunity yeah and I think this goes
back to part of the Silicon Valley's
beauty is people are ruthlessly honest
yeah right and in most parts of the
world sorry yep
okay explain why do you say I mean like
I actually don't think that I would say
it's sort of people are very especially
in the entrepreneur world right if
you're an entrepreneur or I'm an
entrepreneur I go to you I'm like hey I
want to raise capital here's my idea now
you rely on deal flow as an investor and
you don't want me to be saying you want
me to be evangelizing our conversation
that we have and so you don't want to
say your idea sucks here's why bang bang
bang bang bang because so many people
are carrying their dreams to you to make
them happen with you know capital
raising and personally tell it like to
shoot it straight that's fine because
now I can iterate I just want the right
answer but a lot of people are gonna be
like yeah I can't believe you said that
to me like he doesn't like me like how
it it's like he wants to make an
investment and he wants to make like you
are doing them a favor shooting them
straight but you're risking them
bitching about you to their friend their
network and now your deal flow tightens
up
well the downside could be hey he's an
[ __ ] right but but you're not an
[ __ ] shooting it straight this person
if you really want to be like the
spinach and the tea thing oh he's been
an [ __ ] to me especially know he is
trying to save you time your time is the
most valuable asset on the entire planet
we all get the exact same amount of it
it's who realizes that you know it is
most valuable you can't like you can't
earn time you can save it or you can
spend it you cannot earn it so you're
never gonna get more of it so you can
use it wisely I feel like that's a
pretty good saying have you ever seen
the movie with Justin Timberlake in time
trash and I was like I've never even
seen it that one where he's got like the
things on his arm or whatever so for
those they've never seen a movie
basically every human has a clock or
like a countdown clock on their forearm
and you go to work yeah paid yeah time
so looking time is the unit is the
currency and so let's say you go to work
today and you get another 24 hours right
we got to come back to work tomorrow to
get 24 more hours yeah but if at any
point you run out of time you die now if
you are rich you end up having on line
like in outsourcing it right no you just
have infinite infinite amount of time so
you end up with let's say that you know
a hundred century's worth of time or a
better 50 years worth of timer yeah and
then if you are poor you are usually
living with less than 24 hours in the
movie yep and so you know critical poor
meaning hey you have a lot of time yep
so what ends up happening in the movie
is the people who don't have a lot of
time yeah run everywhere right so
they're literally sprinting because they
don't have a lot of time ah and the only
way to get more time is to go to work so
they're literally trading labor for
quote time right so that's kind of all
these metaphors of real life
yeah but the wealthy when they you go to
the wealth zones yeah these are people
who have a lot of time you can't go in
between these wealth zones without
certain thresholds of time yeah yeah
yeah Oh empty is yes and so if you have
let's say more than 20 years of time
they are allowed into you know the
wealthier zone the presidents club
whatever yeah yeah and nobody runs
they're actually running is a sign of
not having any quote-unquote money or
time yes because why are you in a rush
oh yes I have a lot of time yep right
and so the reason why I like the movie
is I really like the premise of this by
the way
yeah it's sorry Justin Timberlake it's
the parallels to life of what are we all
actually optimizing for right we say
that money we say is all stuff but at
the end of the day it's time right and
young time ends up being really really
important and what I think a lot of
people don't do is they don't put a
monetary value on their time right and
it's one of the easiest things that I
tell young people to do which is yep
decide how much your time is worth to
you right how much would you pay to get
an hour of time yep is it five dollars
is it a hundred dollars is it a thousand
dollars what is that yeah and also what
are you willing to get paid in exchange
for your time right yes
so when you come up with those two
numbers hopefully those two numbers
match yeah
in some cases they're they don't match
yeah but when you come up with those
numbers now all of a sudden the
decisions of what you do with your time
become super super clear absolutely this
is this is mind blowing actually that
you're saying this I won I could not
agree more and it I think it becomes
time is that's the currency I mean
that's the the measurement for everyone
right but what people get paid in
determines what's valuable to them and
what they prioritize so if you give me
money for my total like let's say I go
hey I really want an hour of your time
you're like okay cool
I want you and like you might say all
right I want a thousand bucks and that
quantifies out to you your hourly rate
or you might say there's actually you
can give me more than money you can port
five hours of your time on to this
problem I'm trying to solve and that is
more valuable than a thousand bucks yeah
it's fascinating well an end the
education or information may give you
more time later so I'll give you an hour
today that's worth X dollars but it's
because that hour of time today is going
to save me 50 hours of time later one
hour I sin and so what do we call that
when it's capital investment yet right
I'll invest an hour with you today
because you're going to give me
something that later is going to pay off
50 X what I invested yes and when you
start thinking of your time that way as
if it's capital
I think people start changing what they
do yeah I remember my ol boss at work he
was like hey you been doing the same
thing for like four hours
and I had to do this really like
repetitive process yeah 280 times or
something to go through some updates or
something it was like years ago and I
spent five hours and I hadn't done one
of them and it was the case of I'm
really lazy so like as a person I'm
extremely lazy so I will always be like
what's the what's the catch here there's
got to be an easier way and that was me
spending like five hours so that it's
automated so I don't have to do it again
and then you know he was stoked with
that because now no one else in the
future has to do it either and it's like
you know
everything especially an investing right
for you like oh is it a good investment
is a bad investment well what's your
time horizon is Bitcoin a good
investment long long term absolutely is
it a good investment today yeah I don't
know flip a coin like everything is
relative because the value is going to
be relative like value is in the eye of
the beholder right beauties in the eye
of beholder if I've never eaten a I
haven't eaten in three weeks and you
bring me an old cheeseburger I'm gonna
be like oh my god thank you
if I just had dinner and I've had like
beautiful day I'll be like get that [ __ ]
out of here and it's sort of everything
is relative so adding value to anything
is always going to be relative for sure
so one of the things that somebody I
think isn't of all recently tweeted he
said earn with your mind not with your
time yeah usually I'm too stupid to get
his tweet so it takes me like 30 reads
but yes I see yeah right and so the
whole idea is just the value you create
is much more the intellectual value you
provide right in the like manual
resource kind of yeah or just your time
right yeah so if you spend an hour doing
something and I spend two minutes doing
something yeah and I get paid more than
you get paid yeah
does that make me lazy does that make me
smarter does that make me just
understand the rules of the game better
yeah right all these different things
but I think that that was a really
powerful way to kind of our teeth and
these ideas of just like earn with your
mind not with your time yeah and that
changes again behavior because people
begin optimizing for something
differently what are we all optimizing
for right now I mean look we're in a
beautiful office 54th floor
everyone is everyone is chasing they're
chasing something and I had this
conversation at this hacker house in
Tribeca oh yes I think it's right right
yeah yeah that's a place you want
educated but I have thats where you were
but that's definitely sin New York okay
right all right
a bit like how many said what are we all
doing like literally where why are we
going to work well we're going to work
to make money why are we making money
oh so we can pay the rent why is the
rent oh because they want to make money
because they've got an investment like
it all just and you know says Bitcoin
solves this dude like I mean as
philosophical as you want to get call it
[ __ ] call it not [ __ ] the
reality is like it does at the end of
the day if imagine if let's vaporize
money out of the conversation what to
humans do day in day out they'd be
themselves what is that your superpower
like as pomp right nobody can be you but
you that is your superpower that you
give for the rest of the world no you
are that and your originality is what
humans as people at least this is sorry
you get kind of philosophical and [ __ ]
but I mean dude I'm down the rabbit hole
here for six years ten years in Bitcoin
so I give me a break
but the reality is if money is coming
just super easily then what do you do
and it's sort of like you try and think
about people well I look at the people
on x-factor or you know American Idol or
whatever you know you get the seventy
year old of a sixty year old woman that
sings and blows everyone's mind
why does people like that they like it
because one its original they never saw
it coming so that originality sparks a
fire in us and the second part is that
they ask the story or what happened oh
well you know I ended up you know
falling out with my parents when I was
young and then I lived on the street and
I just had to meet make ends meet and I
got an office job and life got in the
way life got in the way of that
and that could have been Picasso
Columbus so whoever everyone celebrates
but that is the problem in life getting
in the way is not oh there was just too
many people being themselves it's the
rent was high the bills got to get paid
da-da-da-da-da and so like I feel like
it's sort of a great thing when you
think about Bitcoin solves this I mean
Bitcoin is the first thing that looks
like a opportunity at money vaporising I
mean like look it's hard money
absolutely but it's sort of going to be
to the point where it makes it not a
thing anymore yeah and I guess part of
this really comes down to we are asking
people to be experts at multiple things
right and I've talked about this before
but I want you to earn a living being
everything from a teacher to a fireman
to a finance professional to an
accountant to you know a marketer
whatever your job is yep and then I want
you to be a professional investor to
protect your wealth right I need you to
do that because inflation is gonna steal
your wealth if you don't yeah and so you
have to understand asset classes
portfolio construction are all these
different things and if you do not
understand those but you still want to
protect your wealth then you need to pay
somebody to protect your wealth for you
right and it's all because
systematically you are incentivized to
get out of cash right now that is a
pretty big problem when you add in this
layer of machines and automation and all
this stuff right people start to worry
about are they gonna lose that income
right and one of the things that drives
me I think to share this with people
because it seems so obvious but but
maybe it's not is that in a world where
automation and machines become so
prevalent and pervasive creativity is
the one thing that the machines are
going to kind of automate last right
it's the human ingenuity and if you can
optimize for a job or making a living
leveraging creativity and human
ingenuity you got a pretty good shot of
surviving the automation wave you are
the last person I yes a trillion percent
agree and this is where it's going
because the like if we think about
machines right and I mean like
investment grew very intelligent people
that dismissed this premise they say
it's far too early I'm like look if you
look at it properly Bitcoin is the
carrot and you know like that experiment
with monkeys right the scientists he's
got bananas and there's
he's ten monkeys lined up they go I want
to banana they grab a banana the banana
is thrown into a room and the door
closed behind them the monkey is caged
so the monkey wanted a banana but now
the monkeys in a cage and it doesn't
have its own ability to do whatever it
wants or whatever so it's caged in now
it does not want a banana
it wants to be itself again it wants to
like just let me out of the cage take
the next 20 bananas don't give them to
me that is if we look at history we were
formerly like before us now which is
like intelligent beings or whatever it's
other than you and I but basically it
was you know Capeman or whatever we
didn't have our brains firing as well as
they are now basically the next
iteration we're in the middle right now
between intelligent like you know until
cavemen and super intelligence which is
computers so if you're a computer right
imagine imagine AI in 30 years from now
and you look back at a capitalist
America and society money hungry ads ads
ads buy buy buy what do you think the
carrot is or the banana to get us into
locked in the cage
it's going to be money right so that's
what honest so people think we're you
know D shackling ourselves from
governments but I mean there's a very
very clear path that that could become
we're actually handing over the keys
from the government to ourselves but
it's actually not ourselves it's
machines controlling our money well and
I always go back to this idea of
creativity is mispriced
right and creativity be at mispriced is
the fact that it's going to actually
appreciate in value over time yep people
don't yet understand that and so
therefore they put a lower price on that
creativity and so if it's an under
priced asset or mispriced asset yep
investing there today will pay off
pretty well in the future and if you
think about where the machines and
automation are going to come in actually
the people who can leverage creativity
and kind of human intelligence and
ingenuity the best the automation is
only going to further the moat for those
who are in the creative business
literally the only thing right now
like you can train datasets for you know
yes-or-no questions is that a flower yes
or no whatever write me a poem and stuff
like that
you know if you look at how this how
this goes if we've got machines that can
do everything for us everyone's gonna be
like oh I want to day in the life of
Drake or I want to do this I want to do
that I want to be this person everyone
starts shaping themselves towards being
the same almost and what's left after
everyone sort of been Drake for a day
and they've been everyone they're like
okay what's next
originality is it that is the that is
the key ingredient that is going to be
the most important commodity of the
future is originality and right now
money squandered like money gets in the
way of that so it like the singer the
artist it was like oh life got in the
way and I couldn't share my voice with
the world that voice could be an opinion
that voice could be Mozart or whatever
who else has crushed it in the past but
like you do a history test they're not
saying hey yeah yeah what was Drake's
first album on that I know is who was
the first person to write this who was
the first person to discover that who
went to the moon first editor
they don't remember second third what
they remember the first and that's
because it is original and it is new and
our brains that's why humans evolved the
way we do is because yeah what's behind
the curtain
we're always looking for [ __ ] and that
evolution of asking asked why and that
iterative process that's that's
literally how we evolved and so like
having the mindset that being knowing
that first or like not managing your own
expectations whether it's in life or
running a company or anything like that
when you know if things are going to
change that's okay and it doesn't mean
you're right or wrong you can just
always like saying it like it you know
on our team is always plan for the worst
hope for the best
end of the day and some people come back
like investors they're like well that's
a really negative outlook I'm like no
that's not a negative outlook that's a
very realistic outlook statistically
probable like and the odds of us being
wrong yeah let's plan for the worst
what's the worst-case doomsday scenario
if we've got a playbook for it then
everything else is cream like yeah this
goes back to
those are very sorry for the Rambo no no
you're you're dead on there's a very
famous approach that nick saban the
cushion alabama and a few other
professional coaches have have kind of
solidified or made famous which is focus
on the process right and do your job and
so in football for example there's
eleven folks on the field yeah and on
offense right well you have the ball
every plays drawn up to be a touchdown
right I've never I've never seen a play
John you mean like the arrows and all
the X's and all that stuff it's a touch
thing every man in 95 they score every
single time on the chalkboard right and
the reason why that doesn't happen in
real life is because one of those eleven
folks yeah doesn't do what they're
supposed to do right so the example I
always give is the quarterbacks job on
you know the play we're about a run is
to take the snap take three steps yeah
hand the ball to a running back right
the guy who snaps the ball his job is
snap the ball take two steps you know to
his right post his right arm lock in the
guy in front of them and then turn and
block anybody comes off the back side
yeah then the running backs job is to
step to the right
run upfield take the ball run through
the whole bubble or whatever and every
single one of those people has a job now
the whole thought process behind do your
job is if you're the center the guy
snapping the ball yeah don't worry about
it the quarterbacks handing the ball off
or not make sure that you snap the ball
you take two steps to the right
you put everybody in that's all right
yeah it's just do your job and if all 11
people on the field do their job on this
play yep we're gonna score touchdown
right that is my boy I didn't realize it
was so non like makes sense sorry go for
broke obviously but I mean and that can
happen in football obviously because you
can get that 60 yards or whatever it is
but I feel like every play no it's not
just the 60 yard touch this is the key
piece of where design where you're
supposed to strategic ways to be like
let's match up the field to start with
it well then go for broke when we're
close to like well so it's not going for
broke though right this is the big
secret and I think there's a lot of yes
to business so the whole idea here is
don't worry about scoring yeah right if
you're the center don't worry if we
score
all you need to worry about is something
very simple snap the ball take two steps
to the right post with your right arm
hinge and make sure you get anyone off
the backside yes right and if that's all
you gotta worry about you don't have to
worry about what play we've run you
don't have to worry about who's in the
game you don't don't worry what the
score is you'll have to worry if we
score or not yep all of that stuff is a
distraction yep just do your job on this
one play yeah focus right now on your
job and do your job
yeah by the way if you trust that the
other 10 guys on the field each do their
job on this play we end up scoring well
yeah so I see you I think that's
interesting but if I was a football
coach I would say will the hold those 11
people at the time they're all looking
at the coach or the manager whoever it
is and saying I trust that you are
absolutely certain that you have
accounted for every permutation of
what's what out what they go throw to us
because that is what's going to cause me
to not do my job successfully which is
going to unbundle all of it as a house
of cards and it's like yeah it's kind of
inch by inch life as a cinch yard by
yard life is hard of you heard that
saying no what is that what it means one
step at a time like you know mean by
inch life is a cinch yard by yard
life is hard so like as in one step at a
time it all fall into place so that's
sort of like you know if you want to go
for a touchdown
yeah like sure you can go for it
probably not gonna be as successful it's
sort of like oh how it takes years to
become an overnight success oh my god
everyone's I could I could have built
Instagram and sold it for a billion
dollars no you couldn't have because you
didn't know all the iterations that they
went to start as a bourbon photo app or
something like that that iterative
process but that was their inches like
one step at a time they didn't go like
look at the evolution of the internet
right people used to knock on neighbors
doors and be like hey morning have you
picked up the paper imagine if I came to
you in 1990 with the internet and I go
hey upload all pictures of yourself tell
me when you got in gate congratulations
by the way and tell me about you getting
engaged where'd you go on holidays I
want to see photos and you're gonna
share these with strangers that you've
never met before you'd be like what the
[ __ ] though but it crept up to where it
is
today and we look back and we're a long
way from Kansas kind of thing but at the
time it's just oh just like you know
your bedroom is like you got Metallica
posters yeah make your own website
that's kind of like your digital bedroom
and then it's oh tell us what are you
thinking and that's your your
consciousness stream of Twitter or
whatever you show me where you are what
are you doing and then you look in
you're like holy [ __ ]
I'm right there with everyone so the
wall gets really small really quickly
because you feel like you're in your
neighbor's house automatically so but if
I said that to you at the start you
would not have bought into it it
wouldn't create success Instagram
wouldn't be popular if it came out day
one of the Internet people would feel
like it's invasive and so to change
behavior which is typically what most
companies that have a huge breakthrough
are trying to do or let's say technology
like Bitcoin it is iterative but you
know that doesn't mean that you should
it's zero 100 is wrongly but both things
can get there in the end if it's meant
to be it's meant to be kind of you know
it'll figure a way out it's just you
want it to take six years or do you want
it to take 15 or 20 years and that's
sort of like a premise even if I am like
let's say a Bitcoin ball and I think
bitcoins gonna you know vacuum in a lot
of the value that we see today is it a
bad thing to have 40 different
alternatives that are trying to throw
[ __ ] at the wall and iterate and Bitcoin
can sort of see that and adopt that over
time like is that gateway drug mentality
the right answer or is it no it is it or
get out of the way what do you think um
I think I'd go back and forth with
buddies around this but I think look at
the end of the day the downside to
gateway drug mentality is I mean the
upside is that you know you get to see
and learn and adopt it if you are a
Bitcoin or if you are you're the biggest
in the room but the downside is
obviously there's a lot of people that
yet can get hurt from that so there's a
lot of scammers and stuff like that
which it it feels like oh that person's
never gonna trust cryptocurrencies
because it's giving us bad name da da da
they're coming back like every bull run
you see your friend you know everyone's
got those tweets or those direct
messages where they told their friends
to buy a Bitcoin in 2013 or 2011 or
whatever it was and they said no then
they don't miss it the second time and
so that's the you know the mob comes
their coming area either way whether we
like it whether we don't with your
government with your poorest person on
the planet it is happening you can just
choose to take a risk earlier or later
and people are usually rewarded for
their risk but the funny thing is is the
earlier people get into it it typically
is indicative of their principles as
well like a lot of the people when
Satoshi makes Bitcoin right
funny thing Craig right Craig right he
was I think he's actually a lecturer at
the university I went to in Australia
which is funny just kidding no I
actually I think he was but I wasn't
there then the when Satoshi makes it
Satoshi has a choice to go holy [ __ ]
I've just invented irreversible digital
money that souls pawn gambling in every
high risk industry but is that the best
way for the network to evolve in a hard
way no it's to go to really brilliant
cryptographers and say hey I need your
eyes on this what are we missing like
let's work let's harden the base and so
like if you look at teams like doing
token sales and stuff you go list on
Finance that's a great payday and I
think bias is awesome for like if you're
a trader and stuff like that but you
know if you've got some sort of thing
that you're trying to control its you're
trying to nurture like raising a child
that's what a like a distributed network
of cells is what raising a child would
be and networks are like biology really
so you want to nurture it so it grows in
the most optimal direction for the core
principle that it was founded to be now
if I find it to be a scam coin or
anything like that I grow it to be a
scam coin but if I'm really trying to
solve a problem or like hard money that
I want a nurture it for the long term
and not take the poison apples which
might be you know short short-term
self-interest
sorry for the how do you guys think
about that at wire right so like who are
the types of customers you guys are
trying to work with so I mean dominantly
its developers you know fin tech teams
brokerages its people who need the
infrastructure it's people that need the
infrastructure so a lot of like
exchanges wallets things like that yeah
we want to get to as many people as
possible because you know we we just
want people to realize like just don't
bother with doing it all again don't go
get the banking relations like this is a
many hands make light work situation if
we all work together we band together as
one which is we take care of you know
everyone bites off a piece of expertise
like we're talking about with people and
their personalities like creativity or
what are you an expert at that I can
extract value from and in return give
you value and those are sort of
harmonious relationships but if you look
at banks now or neo banks right so you
look at an ear bank it is a cosmetic
layer over the best of stock trading the
best of this banking service the best of
international transfers and they bundle
it all together to look like a bank can
they present it much better and banks a
you know construction of five different
pros lending saving borrowing whatever
near banks are like that but they pick
the best of each you know if we look at
how we can build the future of you know
digital assets and digitizing money
generally speaking you know Bitcoin
bites off one of those pieces most
likely though everything will rely on it
because if you look at a digital world
with computers computers have never had
a unified clock let's call it as simple
as that like we look at the Sun the Sun
goes round around that is the source of
energy that provides us with
coordination at scale a clock is the
same thing for machines the Bitcoin
block height sorry
so regardless it's not about whether I
like Bitcoin more than I like aetherium
or anything like that bitcoin is the
longest running track record so if I'm
tenders determine wrong and determine
the most valuable by the market of
course if it it's the problem it souls
is what valued is Bitcoin and it's not
fast enough is it
the only thing it has to do is not
change
imagine if the Sun fell out of the sky
we're like oh [ __ ] we were wrong there
actually there's four Suns whoops
you'd be like huh no the Sun is the Sun
because we know that that thing's been
there the longest thing since the
beginning is to turn on tomorrow man do
you know what I mean
it's just being respectful of that that
is that's the fact call it how you say
it you guys raised money during the
depths of the bear market what was that
like I haven't exceptionally like I said
earlier I was terrible at a lot of
things raising money is one of them but
I think like the most interesting
takeaway when we raise money was
definitely managing expectations so you
know in bull markets and bear markets
and stuff like that you have obviously
peaks and troughs and when you have such
seasonal like financial markets are
seasonal especially financial markets in
a newly adopted technology so to say oh
we're going to grow twenty percent
month-over-month you just no you are not
because you have not quantified every
single contributing factor to be able to
determine that at all so managing
expectations was the best part about
that where I said to and as I said look
we are going to make less money than we
did this year unfortunately I mean sorry
like that was the premise the focus was
on the cool way to determine whether or
not we have done our job is our KPI is
on distribution how is our reach going
because and it's not like let's just get
a bunch of users and monetize later but
it's like it truly is these are networks
networks operate on connectivity and
distribution and tying things together
to create resiliency like that's how our
network is survives it's flat but
everything's connected now that's its
resiliency and so distribution is like
our focus because the tech is there and
there's brilliant people that are more
focused on it more obsessed with that
specific component of it like let let
them be masters at it and then that's
better for us to have a conversation
with them about hey how can we take
advantage of that or how can we add
value to you guys
building this tech and vice-versa so
like you know whatever that tech is I
mean like whether that's yeah there's a
million and one things it could be but I
think it's yeah I think that's just the
way that you've got to play the game and
a lot of people I think the default
setting in finance
generally speaking or anytime there's
money about self-interest self-interest
self-interest self-interest what does it
look like long term when you are not a
company living quarter to quarter and
you are sacrificing self-interest for
what could be the greater piece of the
pie like is it in our best interest as a
company to make our company's stock
worth more or is it in our best interest
to buy a significant amount of Bitcoin
and grow the pie more what is going to
be long-term more sustainable what's
going to add more value what's gonna get
there faster I'm not saying I've just
bought bags bags bit code by the way but
I mean like it's it's a thought process
I mean that is a very legitimate
approach and something some teams that
are very successful in the space they
actually have that approach it's a good
redundancy if you're betting on the
space as a if you're a company and
you're committing your whole life to
this space I mean may as we'll load up
your bags while you're on the playing
kind of thing yeah for sure yeah what um
what do you think is the biggest
challenge in the industry right now
identifying what adds value and what
doesn't add value explain that
nobody focuses on adding value I mean
sorry not nobody very few do what adds
value so I'll give you like so I have a
very big belief that if what browser do
you use on your computer I use a couple
but chrome mostly nice so I was just
curious actually but like how much do
you make off Joe Joe's lab and somebody
came in to see some random question my
social security number laughing because
he's fine through a camera cuz it's
chrome bit like it so Opera browser
right Oprah browser is three two or four
or five percent I guess one of the it's
I think I was in the top five browsers
on like on the planet they have 350 400
million users now that is something that
is
interesting to me because that
penetration is on a different side of
the world so if you have that and every
person on a device with a browser that
can extract value from this like you
know what is adding value is it me like
talking about adding value do we create
a product that gives a five percent
savings to people or borrowing money at
20 percent interest rates or whatever
like whatever's going on in crypto at
the moment who should you target
well value is in the eye of the beholder
if you give someone who's got 30 choices
to create a bank account you say oh I
don't have it it's like try it it's
awesome it's cuz it's crypto or its
Bitcoin it's like whatever they'd like
the switching costs is not worth it
basically I don't give a [ __ ] enough
because there's not enough value to me
to switch now if you go to someone in
let's say Argentina or you know Africa
hey you're not going to suffer like 15
20 percent inflation you will break even
at the end of the if you had a hundred
dollars this year you will have $100 or
$99 50 at the end of the end of the year
Argentina if you bought Bitcoin at the
top of the bull run 20k and you sold it
at the bottom when it's four thirty
eight hundred or whatever you did it was
better to have done that than to hold
the Argentinian pacer of course yeah I
did you're smart I'm not I didn't know
that I was like oh yeah the only reason
why I know that it's because I have
people tweeting at me all the time right
currencies are failing yeah this is it's
getting close to home and it will start
it's gonna happen in the US hyper hyper
inflation is gonna happen in the u.s.
they're already hedging together
interest rate you know manipulations
going qyz raging on and at the cameras
the US or the ECB recently and they
started to hint at the idea of like oh
we may actually allow inflation to go
over the targets put like that's okay
because we're planning on it blah blah
blah blah blah go mighty I'll tell you
what though like if you look at the like
there are different tiers right so you
know you're in the investment side you
look at the individuals that have gotten
into
Doha and Bitcoin there you know really
enthusiastic and thought leaders and
they're rewarded for their enthusiasm
and they're rewarded longer term with
financially when they there was no
incentive at the time to buy it they
were there on principle and then you
look at banks like say silver gate banks
silver gate Bank is a fantastic case
study if in my opinion you know we've
like just obviously where a crypto
company and they specialized in saying
hey we're not gonna dismiss it we're
gonna focus it we're gonna double down
and take a look at it because if there
is something here then we should be
serving it and they're going they're
getting rewarded for their investment in
time now and the next layer on you talk
about like you know o institutional
money's coming in dah dah dah and
there's this whole narrative people are
just sort of frothing at the mouth over
look they'll get here eventually just
make sure you are in beforehand
basically because after them then the
next one is going to be governments and
there's obviously already governments
that do hold Bitcoin and there's
governments that don't and those that
hold Bitcoin early are going to be
rewarded for that investment whether
that's a hedge or a desperation it
doesn't matter it will all come full
circle and you'll find that damn I wish
I could rewind time and there's a time
machine unfortunately sorry yeah I don't
know I don't even know what you ask I
literally just fire hosed you retraction
sorry I love all right let's do well
rapid-fire before we wrap up here most
important company in crypto other than
wire oh man can we cut this no no oh
[ __ ]
make it out why gateway drug that is not
what I expected you to say alright
explores I'm supposed to say I and
that's not a popular answer so I want to
hear why you guys a block stream open no
door make it out and I felt like make it
out right the second because they are up
holding a ton of the come try crypto
like they're under people what are
people's first interaction with maker
Dow or with something else well I mean
the first interactions obviously with
most of the time is Bitcoin but make it
out is providing the all the digital
money that is getting
by G USD USD see packs and all those
guys I mean you would say what are they
competitor to a decentralized stable
coin yeah and would know what they're
doing is that's a crowd-sourced
education on RAM what what is maker Dow
look like ten years from now and do you
think they're still around I would say
make it out yes I think they're still
around I'm excited probably agree with
that yeah I'd say they'd still be around
I think they would have probably
migrated a lot of their you know firstly
they have a lot of different assets and
those different assets would be
underpinned by something more secure so
something like block stream liquid for
example that's collateralized Bitcoin
that is like people are gonna realize
that if it's not the most secure party
in town you're gonna want to be on the
most secure chain and I feel like a lot
of teams may end up migrating maybe not
I don't know my surprise trend of 2020
calling it now I've been calling it for
a few weeks now defy merges with Bitcoin
and it ends I'm all getting built around
Bitcoin
yeah I mean at the end of the day I
don't disagree with that
I don't think I don't know if it's
strange I mean like Friday it may it may
take you a bit all the helots it might
take a little bit more than 12 months to
actually like fulfill the promise but
there will be multiple companies that
get launched to do this in 2020 yes and
I definitely think that that's something
that we look at a lot just purely from a
security standpoint if it's you know if
we're looking at the longer term thing
what does it what does it mean to be on
Bitcoin does that mean oh you got to
build everything on it no it just means
that the lens of truth is the hardest
chained to [ __ ] basically and I
think that means you know if if I was
doing backups and I wanted to prove that
I had something I could put it on chain
a B C D or e I just choose whatever the
longest one is and the hardest of
[ __ ] so that someone can't wipe over
it later and that means that I built
that proof on Bitcoin it doesn't mean
that I had to build all the tech and
stuff it just means the keys sit on that
and the recovery
it's like a backup machine basically hey
that's fair yeah what's the one
regulation rapid fire so what's the one
regulation you would change or improve
if you could I think I would say just
either what investor accreditations or
make it relative to this is
proportionate net wealth everyone's got
enough information how much people earn
same as a figure it out I'm not gonna
touch that right now cuz people already
know my thoughts on Accreditation what
are you thoughts on Accreditation it's
changing the SEC recognizes and they're
gonna they're gonna add some
improvements but shorts long story short
is we should go to an education based
system where people have to take a test
rather than use wealth as a signal for
intelligence yep
and my favorite thing is like how many
dumb rich people do you know I'm looking
at one right just dumb poor person yeah
but no I think that I think that's you
know the biggest thing and I've been
quite vocal about it's a violation of
the American dream
it is discrimination against people
based on wealth and I think it's got to
change
yeah I mean look at the end of the day
people balk loud enough like people that
work at the government they're not
they're just like I mean sometimes like
we've met we have to meet regulators and
stuff and they're not they're like oh
right how can I make your life miserable
they're like yo I've got a Netflix
subscription I like Spotify too
yeah I like to drink beer I want to go
home watch TV they're super rationally I
mean they're human beings at the end of
the day if you can make their life
easier with you know it's kind of a do
you go one step forward one step
backwards to go ten step forwards what
do you just grind against the grain and
give and take so aliens believer or
non-believer
oh I define alien you define it okay
well so the little people the gray-gray
people or whatever you know the little
gray people easy stereotype I would say
that they're probably human beings on a
like that's an evolved human being like
a chimpanzee meeting a human being if we
went to a planet that was full of
chimpanzees that would be like an alien
coming to us so oh you think that
they're way more advanced than we are
the carbon-based same thing that just
have evolved I've been in next iteration
so chimpanzee so we don't want to clash
in a plane
we don't want to come in contact with
them um why don't know if we do or don't
don't but if they're more intelligent
and more developed than they have
superiority over us right
yes I would say so but mmm
then maybe superiority is not important
it's important to us now but maybe they
don't value that like as in we we're
threatened by superiority right you just
say and maybe that's it's because we use
superiority yes we use superiority but
why do we do that I mean like you know
we impose our will because we all have
our agenda because we have to operate on
our self-interest and not what we can do
to add value to the collective group so
if we're always operating on
self-interest
it is a kill or be killed its nature is
metal you know that is who is the apex
predator and it sounds like the alien
coming down from a spaceship or a little
green man or whatever it is is your apex
predator crocodile saltwater crocodile
shoutouts to Louie for this one but
saltwater crocodile this is a great
white shark
that's the apex battle I'd say there's a
wolf superacid why so so so is salt
water crocodile vs. great white shark
who wins who wins I'm convinced now the
saltwater crocodile takes the cake
really yeah I went to really great white
sharks it was [ __ ] it was oh man she's
gotta punch him in the nose right oh hey
have you seen these things you are
second you are the number two person
like in the food chain the moment you
see these you will never feel anything
more primal instinctively like I am
number two food chain like just
immediately they swim at 40 knots an
hour let's at 40 miles an hour
underwater these things are big thick
like they're like a submarine but
they're agile they're fast and yeah
there's a reason I haven't evolved for
you know 3 or 50 million years or
whatever what they're doing is working
just fine yeah what was the most
important book you've ever read
I'm a terrible read on I can't read
really really like yeah I can't
comprehend properly I've I'm really
about a comprehending so I'd do anything
I read I have to read 20 times like as
less times than reading the vols tweets
30 times yeah I'm working on it yeah
he's like there yeah the final boss in
terms of corporation alright to wrap up
I always let the guests ask me one
question where you got for me how much
you make after tax joking you have you
seen stepbrothers that's what they think
I I want to say what's the most
important thing for you the what's the
one thing you're grateful for Forge in
2019 and what is one thing that you
would love to see for yourself as a
person for 2020 what's important to 19
super-easy as pretty much everyone knows
I got engaged so so Polina takes the
cake on that one
and in 2020 it's funny we talked about
time earlier I have I've become much
more ruthless with protecting my time I
made a promise to to Joe who's smirking
over in the corner and Polina that I was
going to travel a lot less in 2020 and
so I've just been saying no to a lot of
things a lot of these conferences etc no
and you know I still have to travel a
little bit but I think this year I
should look it up I think I took more
than a hundred and forty flights that
you're busy dude hundred forty flights
like if you start doing the math on that
that's more than one every three days
it's sounds like you play for a baseball
team hoping yeah so no no by the way no
discipline he's a modern-day superpower
when everything like know is alright so
I suck at saying no that's literally
what I'm getting I used to suck I'm much
better at now no no you know what yeah
that's awesome yeah alright man listen I
appreciate you doing this super excited
I what you guys are building I think
that a lot of people across the the
industry are starting to realize that
the the infrastructure isn't necessary
and it's quite difficult to do on their
own so they are coming to you guys so
thanks so much for the work I appreciate
you having me thanks guys
yeah all right we'll do it again soon
thanks pump